hey i'm ryan right I'm Brady price so
today I'm gonna introduce brandy to a
game that I'm gonna do a let's play for
on this channel that my girlfriend is so
excited for and that Brandy's gonna love
to
it's called hatred this trailer is the
devastation gameplay trailer I'm not
sure if this trailer is gonna convey
what the plot is so let me just give it
to you right up front okay it's about a
guy who has a lot of hatred and he goes
on a killing spree murdering a bunch of
innocent people and that's the game
[Music]
because he's a mass serial killer
murderer and it looks [ __ ] intense
let's watch this that's why I hit a man
the first trailer shock the [ __ ] out of
me devastation gameplay let's see what's
going on god I'm somewhat excited it's
tense violence blood and gore strong
language like [ __ ]
human scum they've always felt so
[ __ ] safe inside their homes
surrounded by the possessions gathered
their whole life
so so fragile
they don't deserve a natural death
now just reading repeal
like my a tree oh my god parasites the
walls see
everything
was that it right as bad as the first
one I know the first one was worse okay
cuz I feel like it was bad it certainly
was bad but I feel like the graphics if
it had been more realistic it would make
it so much worse that's advice for you
creators of hatred if you have time make
it more realistic Oh real attention to
detail don't like it it's cool when
you're doing a flamethrower to a house
and stuff but I'm talking about like
when you're murdering the mother of such
a it just cracks me up it just now
plugged up in it but you got to admit if
you ever have imagined or fantasize or
even cooked up a story about a serial
killer who you know goes on a killing
spree I don't know nobody okay maybe he
does that in his crazy imagination me I
don't fantasize about killing people why
not
because that's wrong it might be
interesting to step inside of them like
are you brave enough to step inside of
living vicariously through a mass
murderer are you willing to go that this
should be in 3d this should be one of
those games and you just put on your
head and then you're like living in it
the first person point now I don't think
so ya know and I want and more than just
shooting and hitting like you know you
should be able to like rip off people's
heads and stuff anyway guys thanks for
telling me that trailer was out I wanted
to introduce Brandi to that game if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects Brandi has
a channel does a lot of reactions on
there to check it out and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where we're gonna give a shout out
instead of a product placement sex trip
Damien Cortez yo can I get a shout-out
on Twitter no I'm a huge fan
here's your shout-out instead the fact
that you asked for Twitter just angers
me I want to rip your head off pull off
your penis and shove it up your ass
alter the theme of MORTAL KOMBAT alter
the theme of Mortal Kombat while plain
hatred Damien Damien is also the devil's
name according to demon dude if you're
anything like the devil you're gonna
have a good time playing hatred I just
want you to play hatred and also you
know if you have family problems
imagine them okay some stuff I say is
really [ __ ] up shout out Damien